[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the Super Smash bro
oh my god and I step around look at the
GameSpot stream Super Smash Bros
ultimate we've had the game for a little
while now so we've got all the
characters we're gonna play around on
some stages show the maps off show off
all the new characters so let's get in
it we're already ready to go or start a
game now
heck yeah you're right I mean I clearly
I'm not ready after that intro it's okay
welcome and we'll also be monitoring
chat so feel free to drop in questions
John Luke's checking it out so you guys
have any questions go to certain
characters motors yeah modes whatever it
could be there's a lot in this game and
if you haven't been keeping up you
probably wouldn't remember or see all of
it yeah just let us network I think we
got things but in the meantime we're
gonna do a basic three stock smash game
we have items on I know a lot because we
don't like items but with people it's
kind of fun
really happy to show up the game for the
first water yeah three scared
and woof
so who's even having a lot of fun
planner so I feel like that's it that's
the most important thing to talk about I
think in this point yeah I'm always like
somebody feels really good I understand
Ross I feel like a smash expert collect
detail the exact I think the biggest
thing for me is the retain uses grab to
be like you're gonna be playing tomorrow
no yet only about promises of your
recovery it's really bad it's like i'ts
but his side doesn't have any like
horizontal travel so you can't get back
on the stage really stupid one of those
isn't real anyway you were saying
it's sort of it's faster than light is
it's faster than what we knew I think a
little bit faster than they've been
closer to Meili but it's still like
closest to the video I think most people
have played a lot of before there's a
lot of explosives I feel like I also
want to say that I'm really play as any
character you guys want to see so if you
have a care if you want to see I'll
embarrass myself doing that play you're
kidding this is all yours oh right yeah
I lost big time
they should have a pic of the fight
banger oh he's picking the music the
soundtrack is phenomenal everybody's
here
well so sick so chance just like all the
other crap just call if you want we shop
at you got two of them is there any
characters chat yeah
I'm Supriya global I really like it
sounds like Richter who actually like
quite a bit mr. Steinman but I also
really like tinkling yeah it's really
cool I think wings roll a lot because
they like dip under the stage the only
problem I have an inkling is that you
need to like hide to get your ink up and
you know really like chaotic imagine
it's almost impossible it's like really
sucks it's like a bossing over B Japan
okay I'll get thrown around somebody's
ass gave this moniker for new players
somebody's in place yes I would say so I
mean the classic mode you can make
pretty easy and it ramps up as you play
which is pretty nice and if you lose
it'll get easier I think they did that
in Wii U as well and then the story mode
is a good learning it is it called world
of light
got a fun way oh it's not up on you to
be our human progress is up on our site
yeah and it's a good progress because we
haven't had the opportunity to really
test the online there nothing
oh yeah no we're doing the whole very
high then I mean I don't think you can
properly call it a full review and told
me but what exactly might have been ten
minutes
also because I'm just dumb I can never
remember how I said I know I get I need
like sit down so I think you can write
trigger and B to do it anytime there you
go and then it's just here any if you're
out Thank You fella meeting that hey you
know that's what we're here for we're
having for having a good time you know
in this school that you actually have to
play configure Incas in attendance I
play with that fire on one character
which by replay was prom but I can play
those fire inspector
is there enough fire blowing characters
to do a full eight eight smash with that
probably no but I think like you can
technically do like male and female core
in and then male and female Robin and I
think that really happens a lot later
they don't - exactly
[Applause]
there's right Roy from mark with - yeah
it's it's such a little thing every time
I got to begin from the controller is
maddening
unfortunately that's a hard thing - I'll
try - I'll try to you'll click less
I'll slow my rule calm down I would love
to oh no I think until it's right so
that's a design why we get the colors
I'm doing it oh my god I lost it I think
you're right word it's like because
myself the proper tool is like totally
fine it's just more like Ubuntu the
layout yeah so like I forget what it's
called but there's like a move that you
do in the other ones where you like have
your shield up and drop through
platforms I think club just shield
dropping and like that was easier to do
while moving with the game view control
cuz the ridges on the control stick
because you could easily do diagonal Wow
all right but like I'm not really on
that level so I was like yeah
[Music]
Alessia musket is here this is great I
gotta get that Perry you have to break
the bottle which is pretty tough to do
okay it's the point makes sense because
that I think fully heals you what
characters if you can like it then I'm
thinking camera whatever that's nice
make I like I like the changes we made
the link I like how they've managed to
make all of the links feel the
difference
no yeah it's kind of jumping across the
screen oh like it's I John it was
touched on earlier but it's really hard
for me to explain how or why I think
feels like thirty five damage the link
feels very different I like playing in a
lot yeah I look like Donkey Kong revival
norio feels like Wario so 59 you're nice
not anymore if your warrior main expect
more the same
he's a very good addition yeah look at a
surprise there's no like a trap or like
yeah yeah we're not together sorry to
Zelda
thank you eat credible then I see Pichu
I can play peachy GameCube controller we
would after works for this version yes
that's what we're playing with however
it still has two ports or still you
still need to have plug-in slots law and
two USB slots there's only three on the
dock so I don't think you can do like a
full eight person we just got a hold off
even 1000 to release those new docks
with all the extra USB ports that's
gonna be the next thing it like baffles
me that they haven't figured out how to
like make this thing work with just one
USB plug I don't know why you need to
once cuz they're not like must be jolly
yeah
[Music]
different elements
yeah his mum's grave the truth whole
Muirfield different from Bajor
[Music]
so that's another doctor's so holy feet
you can make out there I don't you let
me see let's see well so wants to see
the difference the game sounds super
loud I'm gonna pay strolling back I was
able to adjust that let's just turn to
Joe oh thank you tech with the cousin is
over now someone mentions I would
someone I think Donkey Kong is weak to
see I feel like this lot stronger than
he's ever been which might not be like
saying that he's strong yeah they were
saying these we can like otherwise the
network oh yeah worried wondering if you
gotta bring back I I feel like he's
actually viable now is like the
character you can play if you want to
haze like paint you actually good now
[Music]
Picchu I think still has their own tier
six still hurt themselves without yeah
what their top tier and adorableness and
that's like new business but gets tired
oh I heard I think that was the thing
about Picchu is that like they left a
secret unlock that you had to do like a
ridiculous amount of stuff to get and
then you little war this like oh
characters or persons and then you play
mooching right right now that's that's
that's the ticket
I'm playing peachy like Ben plays DVDs I
I have a particular play style for sure
trolling yeah
in so many words maybe like this so mad
at you when you're walked right into
that one
Oh bro dogs here I don't even notice
that's why I called out I have known all
the community to plant my tree here yeah
hey doodle is this platform it's like a
perfect tree plant Thanks
[Applause]
look forward to our next year spot
feature top 10 places the country the
tree villager headed to soon I don't
pull out of Somalia
what's that the chaplet secede Pikachu's
ultimate peachy's ultimate all right
back off guys I get this oh my god Bing
turn that off what's the worst that
mushroom is oh my sure it's fried
whenever I feel it off real rough is it
if anyone dang it if anyone wants to see
particularly liked settings for
containment can you show that off I will
chop the stage morphing I think that's
really cool oh he's like I feel like a
lot of people kind of forgot about stage
morphing and it's yeah right no that's a
new feed yet it's it's I think it's
really cool no make Street I think we
just turned it off until Amy come on can
you pick folk some stages every time the
DJ has to pick two different songs and
that's that's a lot to do it's a lot to
ask because you pick Sonic and then you
pick solder and then you pick we Shop
Channel both we shop channels
[Music]
I just kind of got the middle hat oh the
tree yeah good so satisfy yeah you get
rid that bomb that was too much
the only problem with young link is he
doesn't have any c4 now that you mention
it I think that's P cheese problem -
yeah yeah how are you dad
jeez don't worry Chad I'll get the Smash
Ball for Pichu
[Music]
oh no you're actually did shoot no I'm
done I'll just wait oh what's that you
want to see me test down bend okay buddy
hopefully so I hurt myself too if I had
turned
the reason they're pearly percentages
now is because of feature because some
of his moves just because I don't think
that a perp is just a fastball this is
where showing things off you only get it
I do it's it's like this hi Ben don't
embarrass oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there you go
dang job you with that I got a DJ oh god
oh god
why why Oh Jay laughs gonna faint a
still broken uh still good I don't know
feel good broken
I think she's much more manageable now
[Music]
what's the it's not coming I don't think
they had to play they pick that up
people just now mentioning random
characters for smash like looks like I'm
really excited small Chester cheeto
Chester cheeto for smash no I mean long
I'm stay away fashion show striking oh
girl please drink to this like injector
smash down baby oh my beautiful new I am
can you guys try to load where you have
HP you choose just and I'm sure I'm
definitely her stock yeah I don't I
don't play much Dan
Wow it's because they default to stamina
don't they like oh no it's it's default
of the way that it is about which
channel is like an additional option you
can do just apparently ambitious you
just nice we're gonna dive it I think
you've done that more than anyone else
nests like in our sessions just like
Aria feel different
I haven't played enough Lucario to be
able to see
but the Mario Kart retribution the spiny
shell it's here oh no sorry about the
clicking I'm sorry I don't don't this is
this is this is smash oh let me build my
help
the yellow Mouse what's about Pichu
being the worst character I think we're
just bad looking thank you all so I
think it's it's a thing just for Pikachu
and maybe Pete you but when the screen
goes in when you pick your characters
and their eyes light up it's actually
the cheeks Oh Michael is written for you
in the chat yeah yeah do we want to show
what's appeal accent what's so what's
strike teams are things right agent that
you pick like teams of characters to
take in tights okay we're gonna do yeah
let's try that sure yeah okay whoever's
in control they will have to back out of
it that is me someone else's play
Jigglypuff no here let's desam he's
actually good also tomorrow if you guys
think you can beat us we're gonna be
doing a community string yeah we're now
we're gonna do a community Friday stream
where we're gonna try and play against
you guys so oh my lord I try to get your
babe but it'll be a fun time though
we'll have fun we're also hearing some
mention Ganondorf Daniel shrill cool now
okay well I should go the other way like
what ah 99 minutes what yeah dude
what the ultimate the ultimate smash
dude everyone is here what are you
calling it it's just I don't know just
talk huh I love you that'd be a good
thing for for Peter Browns pit you just
have a constant 37 our match of smash
playing in the background all right
maybe we do big battle fit yes sure
we got the the break the targets in here
probably right since a that's a jam
there it is targets
[Applause]
it's also the play can lift maximum
Lobby and online reverse 3585 3v3 so I
think it's only 2.0 okay that's why
that's fine
no no worries it shut off I think you
guys want to play people that people
recommending someone sub can someone say
Ganondorf they had a particularly puff
and big one for me then I'll pick like
this way of displaying the characters
he's healing good yeah I like this oh
yeah why do people want their was Judy
puff there was bayonetta but your little
there was Ganondorf 10 yes oh you can
take your amigo I can't play any of them
that's don't ask her
[Music]
and I'll I'll dear Isabel Chappell yeah
that's the plate thank you thank you I
had a dream that they would say oh my
god like we mentioned that yesterday I
was like no I really want that no way I
can just do it that way yeah the UI for
this is really good do you ever this
won't be a smooth smooth yeah I guess
hey or how are you can you can this is
real deep you get to throw people off
that's this is remember Jake if you kill
Isabel you're a cop season s-sure I mean
Ganondorf Ganondorf sorry
our key is definitely a pop house phrase
you can't touch Isabel
Isabel's pure unless you're going over
the target Jam [ __ ] gray fox in the
chest and better use the gray foxes
trophy oh oh very exciting whenever he
pops up and the doors closed away he's
very good she's very good apparently but
he doesn't he doesn't feel like an echo
of Captain Falcon anymore which is ice
he has a sword
yeah the sword intention is yeah oh wait
I still have to fight your Ganondorf oh
I really like the presentation in this
manner yeah they're a thing okay
jean-luc oh geez okay I had the button
sake
oh yeah coz your honor this approve oh
no let me see
sorry people want to see bayonetta can
we pick the big stage where dude I know
I figured it would be like I was gonna
be and I figured if you'd like to switch
out in the battle like and wouldn't like
stop that yeah I wonder if there is a
way to have like six people playing in
each person pick around character so you
can actually spit off in the real teams
well it looks like you can name each
character like you can give given
different tags so you go like past the I
mean still do like yeah it's very true
all right kind of to people characters
but not too human yeah
I suppose our human know this is a cool
doing your reticle nope didn't get it
oh just bear yeah that's know yeah whoa
didn't even finish it's going great
alright y'all loose beep remember ba or
switch that's the thing you got out from
there you're fine okay all right
actually I guess they're kind of laid
out this well don't think about it that
way it's just like just like finding a
variable X or Y
a good a good music pic yeah I'm diggin
miss break the targets hello
I hate this mushroom yeah that mushrooms
bad Oh No if that's some of you thing
and I like to kick that bond but I think
it might be a lot most imbalanced items
in the game yes give that Maserati
[Music]
I love my big sword it's a big sword
it's got an eye on it
what's it from I'm not sure I thought
like makan or something about it so I
don't I don't know if there is a monster
on the shore that looks like that but
just a big sword and symptoms we makes
me think ma stronger if any one of the
shadows with this surah Naas let me know
let us know just let me know
just let me know holding me
[Music]
which one's real oh god I don't actually
yes quick let's consult the back of the
box what's the real logo no need all
that food
I thought it was the other one maybe
that's my problem is how no the smash
load that's life
[Music]
Oh your cell yesterday yeah all right so
it says please show custom balance
Justin what custom balance I'm not sure
what that is I think I know what that is
I'm thinking I think I know I'm not sure
how to get to it he says play as Daisy
I'll play it Daisy despite I got a
little let's go in there better how'd
you she'll drop me again their shield up
there doesn't you do it how are you so
good at that if the car is not
believable
I was watching like a thread someone
made the other day about like all the
new language no no no no no changes
they've made to like that counter isn't
stopping it's going real deep and oh
yeah well no I
this is too deeper so yeah the hop
attack being like adults in thing where
you just pressing jump and attack at the
same time I'm pretty cool yeah it's
really fascinating I was just like oh
man I'm not that mean to smash some
people are very just blazing about like
hey check out like here's me playing it
and I'm like are you like worried about
like a Nintendo like getting none this
grader in the lab they need to get these
things out to the people
[Music]
can we see inkling I'm happy to play
inkling again at some point as I highly
think oh we've got to take it to the
final destination version of mom or it's
ours too with that that good Sam
I keep trying to toad you and I'm not
I'm not doing a great job how that
smoker I'd have missed Oh
Simon Belmont now sure I like Simon but
I feel like I like Greek there better
it's just a goddamn trophy uh she's got
more Jojo energy than Simon yeah Richard
good oh heck yeah yeah yeah can you play
the story in coop I don't know the story
than you knew classical coffey toplane
yeah stay away cuz I'm bull picture sake
yeah the backswing did a clash guess so
oh it's like Soul Calibur with golf
clubs any characters that need nerfed
I've been leading an effort Gardner I'm
assuming need to be there I need to be
here I don't feel like we've had anyone
play victim it feels like there's just a
room yeah now is your hard to say
there's so many wait for the DLC
character it's very weird looking yeah
probably
I'll be way too powerful is it huh nice
for can you please play thousand sure we
have to evaluate this down there don't
list of people okay I'm playing it's
Daisy yes I wants Daisy back at it - is
my boy drama
[Music]
let's do try to change the rules better
throw some items turn on speaker no you
chose state Norfolk yeah yeah yeah we
should probably show off this because
it's really cool yeah how much you can
with customized like we've been doing
losers pick for stage selection so the
loser gets to DJ if someone sees the
mushroom before we shut it out cuz I
don't see it
which one is the choice room and the
pink one right there with the legs I was
on it hey there was something else for
the Raptor yeah - wait oh the bug
they're all in the same room perfect
yeah get rid of that round I don't see
enough of that banana pop up and that's
through the biggest injustice save more
if it's cool
that's totally random yeah senator ray
though Brenda makes it outside not
random I was right I need to train him
before just do every two minutes
Dara that every minute every minute
OBJ's launcher 800 dog leashed
[Music]
that's an interesting image receive it
okay which stages should we do oh yeah
it's a good part which should be a
little careful we like yeah polar is on
the table cuz it makes a really loud
noise yeah we're already loud enough
with the click I did like the thing
where I hit the team ember that was bad
[Music]
Bush blushing something Cthulhu Griffin
says the fakes match ball doesn't move
as much oh goes messed up that's how you
can tell me their thing it might also
not look as much I want to keep an eye
on why yeah was the Hot Tips loving the
music made many music creations at the
menu theme yeah if you could play before
you do it it actually keeps that music
on it'll keep playing a white paper
carrier yeah which is a cruise goal it's
a small little thing but I appreciate it
it's cat what's up hope you guys are
having a great time we are heck yeah
you're having a lot of fun oh yeah
someone want to play can I can picture
once I can do it you can
I'll do I'll do inkling so it's
mentioning that I think that's one we
just unlocked to premier league you're
at Astoria ads anyone ought to play rock
sound mention law
oh I'll pick Rob later on no no no
that's not read okay it's a Bowser right
yeah some some Howser I'll do inkling
there's no mention that I want to see
that again
they actually don't know her clothing
options okay
[Music]
scoffing yeah knock off enough
she's not gonna yeah there's more like
Victoria yeah
Daisy boss talks so good well and
enflamed each for what 15 years apart
for me just on principle as far as
gameplay else we say she's no she's very
very much the same but I hate these it's
just the present yeah it's tossing items
off the side I still won no oh so much
that's what snake oh I've heard that
that's pretty good
[Music]
yeo-hwa Bowser side smash is so cool
gathers Yanks
yeah play ken cannery wait this is a
tiger like some of the echo fighters
like they say their echo fighters with
someone like these were actually pretty
different like Rob and Roy I think are
pretty daisies like a different file
smash right and he's got a different uh
up and up and B recovery it's more like
ice like ice oh my god I just died at
all certainly right Oh God
[Music]
how's uh is a bad showing for Kenan I
apologize this that was free new person
who has four inkling
oh I've been around don't you still have
in their life
[Music]
it's also really cool to see these older
stages bumped up like if their visuals
and back in like it's like the exact
same texture which is really clean
yeah I love these those pretty to pick
two songs more than you get to pick two
stage kiss and I write well like when
you do the the stage more thing yeah but
you get to pick two songs back hi oh I
see yeah I am the vibration oh and flip
in judge sitting there ready to jump out
and win yeah that's cool and then his
son you might be a little bit biased
items in than that that's okay
this is a pendulum it's really good to
see so many good jams I know exactly
what the first one photo exactly both
I'm gonna pick our
Oh
[Music]
all that work also that baseball uh it's
pretty good
yes real wacky and that you can throw it
in then it teleports anywhere like that
happening like that I'm not entirely
sure where that's from either look let
me do it where the baseball yeah
isn't there a Mario baseball game I'm
just at me it's just baseball
really yeah I want to see like I can be
from that game could you I mean this was
baseball I am NOT doing well here
[Music]
Oh Dan how fast you get the character so
what we unlock them like every time you
start out by getting a new character
every match you play and then it slows
down a bit but it doesn't get past like
I think like the most was like every
five games and I was looking it up and I
think the actual timer is every ten
minutes you get a shot at a new person
there's an internal timer which is why
that method for restarting your game
works
okay there's a corneria classic mode
right yes everyone as well I'm gonna
take that away but I'm gonna keep its
don't really want Ridley we do really a
myriad liquidly let's see yes I remember
what galleon people are looking for
Ridley someone snake someone else to
play snake somebody want Rob I'll play
go play sake no I get it Rob I want you
to justice I've seen that color for
Ridley is there anything else thank you
uh-huh and rifice myself
Oh somebody oh I'm jiggly puff yeah
jiggly puff was a while ago
there's also a couple others Captain
Falcon sonic and Simon I can do Simon
after cuz I've been playing the Richter
[Applause]
Ben we like to do sonic after that you
do sonic oh we're all sonic stage now
though
having no idea because speed of sound
that places to go gotta follow my
rainbow I promise I won't sink too much
but a little hard not to I think they
should just meet the game audio I only
have that let me have you seen oh and a
little bit of steak I'll do this all by
a leap up the shame I think I think we
none of us not gonna play that scripture
support yeah this is just like us no God
yeah I'm for snake that hurt me more
than most things
Lily's real mean yeah oh yeah we've been
doing this like every night at the
office or a wife boss the songs this is
my favorite song I think that has been
added in this whole game and it might be
like a like a bias like Donkey Kong
Country thing tracks yeah no not in the
middle I want to be in the middle you
look it's um it's a mariachi rap remix
like hate that it's really
[Applause]
we're doing working around getting a
movie I imagine is he's really hot lunch
is probably tapping it maybe yeah
god I love how you can play it the c4
full road
yeah be what you do it like anywhere
it's great
[Music]
a man came to the kosher are cliquey
speed uh-oh oh no dad I'm right here
fly away Oh my way drum yes yes
and helpful fuel I was robbed Oh oh my
god Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's just amazing I actually really like
rock now there is not bad
how's the lag online so we haven't a
chance to really know we have it and
that is why our view it's currently in
progress but you can read okay
so I will pick Simon I know someone's
been asking for that like a mini sanic
you'll be sanic alright let's see
someone says please play Isabella Oh
Isabel so it's Oscar asking for Kirby
there's just a lot of people Dark Samus
so I would be curvy I'll think what's
going on don't take whatever is left
over
oh I know oh hell yeah it's peep run out
yet no I think I'm very know they've
named an announcer yeah it's up so I
mean we don't know but that's kind of
what this elusive later on well people
are suspecting they're gonna win asset
tonight at the Game Awards because I
suppose we February and she's gonna be
there I would count on a playwright I
think today had a little things like
February 29th a song that I think then
probably not something different maybe
one else one of the new characters so
they're out some banjo finally that's
what I've been waiting for who did I say
I was gonna be a sonic oh yeah I said I
was gonna do I believe you were gonna be
whereas other
some of the hike do you wanna be like I
can do that I'll do Isabel next sorry if
I don't if I miss your thing they're
thorough they're a lot coming in real
fast
well we'll try to make it right it's
your to ice this one can you customize
the menu theme yes so when you pick your
song for the stage if you hit play you
know like play and then I'll keep it
within the character flexor oh hello I
said this before but I promise sonic is
that all this special version just turns
into a ball yeah he's like cop boring to
play like I think I'm pretty decent with
Sonic at least by like casual standards
but like boring it's kind of a show-off
cuz it's a little chaotic but if you are
a Castlevania fan they do a lot of
really cool stuff doctor like where you
can actually do like the chain like and
then like where you like wacky little
mounds of ice or when I hit somebody
[Applause]
it's my favorite thing about I kisses up
smash is so good doing this on
oh yeah Oh No
what okay as them
oh shoot why would you do this
sorry I was in it's huh oh I did it
anyway okay I didn't
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah okay hi I'm so bad at this stage
think I'll add a shadow the hedgehog one
of these days history
come back but I guess that means
probably not
[Music]
Joseph in the chat train counting on ya
if anyone asked me if anyone want to see
a particular stage as well let us know
young link or sheep i get your sheep not
you
I know you don't wake yep oh my god oh
god we gotta be showcasing the stage one
feature we actually are right now man oh
yeah all right we're getting some
recommended Oh Kevin Falcon so I'm
really lost haven't found it oh all
right
no bill can you mess with gravity in
settings can you can live this week the
trainer never seen a lot we fit trainer
I think ready to go for but then weep
the trainer instead of over those couple
others super stage if somebody wanted
final destination and someone along a
castle siege okay so we can do both of
those we're in stage one look at the
stage Morphin so this is a good thing we
hit up two stages at once
that's neat so let's scale the station's
up top top all right
do you want a bill here the final
destination personalization that one
it's a song
trophy rush that one all right and where
is it should be in like the bottom third
because maybe like at the top end of it
because it's sorted by like when they
came out oh go up one from where you
just were oh go for one
I don't know arena ferrets it's close
Isis this the dogs are you just okay
there we go
I was very wrong so this is interesting
cuz Castle siege actually has its own
stage transitions I don't know any of
these oh yeah this would be both sort of
transition under transitions that's
great I don't know any of these songs
here up for its new remix so it it could
be a thing yep that's a jam my favorite
my favorite songs of fire emblems you're
okay you're up for what please play the
cast breath of the wild theme tells
music over we should we should hope that
we only say this plan okay I was gonna
play sheep this is beautiful a captive
[ __ ] or you better Captain Falcon so
much for Kirby awhile ago do you want it
Kirby they just didn't oh you did cook
so you're doing this not okay and then
young link sorry everyone's recommending
characters we'll get to them all Derek
I'm so sorry I'll try and do our best
everyone's here everyone there's only
four of us so far no one's asking for
any of the me fighters though I'm
surprised
[Applause]
so happy yellow link is here right you
smashed oh hey
no something with like masks and such
yeah exactly
he's a good boy but he's definitely put
your ring like a ring in your pocket
that is cool yeah he like puts on a mask
and becomes like a taking like oh thank
you scrubber oh no what is it yeah man I
gotta go deviatoric yeah well 20%
probably not come on oh definitely
everyone's going back over there doing
art actually do you want to make some
gifts or something that's cool
we love gifts here I'm just like doing
different stuff cuz Isabelle has really
cute like stop sign stop sign is that
look forward to the future employers on
ironically like sharing stuff on point
huh yeah that's like not oh yeah sorry
my my portfolio is on tour top
oh no you got party popper oh yes
who is my fishing going to pick up the
armor that's the but it's the best thing
fishing rod is the best move right yeah
Cecily I'm not doing right I need to
talk with my someone we're good I don't
those like the worst Captain Falcon is a
cop yeah he's a cop it is quarter
percent a cop that's the new tier system
is cop - not a cuff link is on a cop but
you probably like it ah I'm not a back
kick I was like I'm so strong it looks
up to them
chicas not a cop she's a princess yeah
cuz she's all know she's like a good cop
though one of the few referring to the
staff roster
[Music]
okay
Oh No let me build my hospital I don't
know
nice pirata we're talking about a hub
for hub so host creators yeah someone
really wants the Metal Gear theme to
play and so we get him got that on he's
Walker theming here and I learned that
last oh it's very exciting middle down
left up next to Luigi's Mansion area
yeah oh there we go
yeah um was also saying that peace
walker yeah yeah we do believe Walker
wait this is no it's the really good one
that plays during the really emotional
part in five also just the theme of
Peace Walker what's the credit song for
Peace Walker cuz I own ironically love
it the one that's a super anime yeah
yeah not the remix though pretty good we
won't even have the original one
no you have to buy it it's the remix
every nice yeah bricks is good
I was just also kind of like I think we
should do
Tom nooks so what would it some Zelda
music right oh right yes yes great plot
toe yeah let's do that but the
battlefield first oh sure it's that
center part of the towers we wanted I'm
gonna mention something
whatever they want to think a sustained
oh good choice okay so let's see if
someone really wants in similar ambiance
if you want it I'm not gonna diet anyone
really want to sever our it so wants Wii
Fit trainer oh I can handle that it's a
narrow dark to save us awhile by famine
someone's asking for that and then
someone wanted to link so I can take
that I was good that I need our services
I'll take it cost is also good yeah yeah
talk to Senator crab because the only
downside to all of the versions sneakier
is none of them have the lyrics in it oh
there you go Alexander asked for me
sword fighter yeah what I didn't hear
that I we had a couple if you
legitimately want me to do it I'll do it
I won't be happy about there's there is
also a cloud recommendation Oh Howard
Eisley cloud I'll be a bee sword fighter
performer class hey at least I didn't
have to fall off the stage well well
it'll change I know
[Music]
consider our seems pretty cool I just
like my Easter and bright
oh there I go
how much amigo yeah hey tomato
[Music]
ain't gonna cat can you set which assist
trophies are available as well good
question
cuz I think old jeans are like similar
like Pokemon like just drop specific
Pokemon that suck
oh yeah like all the legendaries class
easy to stop the basketball well you
still get Legendary's in that oh it's
just not know what up man I'm so scared
I don't think this should kill me haha
dang I forgot
how was the Wii Fit trainer eight
hundred eighty two percent not dead both
yikes let's have a tiny fight okay let's
see if I can make this don't do it Jake
don't do it yeah he's so user country so
difficult
[Applause]
hmm oh you just sit there's but we could
find yourself doing push-ups really it's
good watching hello banana you finally
got it
it's here doctor everything's sorry what
a tip is at his side B is also good for
recovery too so cool
oh my god yeah here trying
[Music]
Oh Oh
[Applause]
plain cake Oh God
oh there I go can you guys tell them the
trip mode from brawl is a fine that's
that even possible
that'd be really funny if they put that
in yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's good enough yeah then I was
complaining with the joy Khan's
Oh Rena was doing that Oh Mike try to
enhance I was pretty bad but he also
like didn't have the bow ties man that
actually gives me bumpers yeah so that
doesn't seem like the ideal way to play
[Music]
survive imagine doing like that but
stretch your place uh-uh
okay I'm trying what people will
recommend a mess someone since Ness well
be nice sauce is Bayonetta again
how do you do Bayonetta again but I want
to see if there's any fat people we
haven't done yet
[Music]
oh the red some want a cloud Rosemead
snort fighter the Sun oh can you
transition from tongue city in the town
of City oh my God we're getting so many
recommendations here oh you have to do
with a different status
hello weird so you could do two
different tongue cities if you really
want we brought enough darts and this is
better than regular Santa's oh no no
it's hard to tell me I mean a patrician
of the same moves Oh perfect yes I want
to say that a dark savers might be a
little stronger but not as fast but I
could be rolling out a row
I haven't played much of either how do
you have this we got a review copy yes
that's the only way to get it early okay
so we got a lot of recommendations so am
I being cloud or Mike being-ness um pick
which one you want there's also a
recommendation for Lucas as well I'll be
Lucas Scherr no cloud there's me sword
fighter someone's asking for it you want
I'll do it cuz then it means I don't
have to play cloud it'll get caught
another good Street Oh game and watch
I'm just gonna let someone told
something Kali's likes Robin okay rule
oh okay thank you rule later on zero
success oh okay
but I I'm not that says Jake's much
better change says will be tracer babies
where is she PK freeze her examines
regular samus I should know Oh
dr. Mario littlemack smash I'm not good
with dr. Marty
I'll do like so dr. Mario if you're
curious I think I figured out the order
of publication so it's by game but the
net go fighters are next to each other
so the top is the first and then it goes
into the ones from melee but then
there's echo fight that's why we see us
up there
there it goes to brawl but then there's
echo fighters that's why I don't know
who necro fighter is from brawl but
anyway and then it goes final Angeles
turn and then wheeze which makes sense
now but I think I'd still prefer if it
was just by franchise yeah like anyone
else I only had a jelly yes 60 frames
per second dot seems to run smooth yeah
um pretty smooth handheld - I know a lot
of people don't like playing handheld
though because there's a lot on the
screen I didn't make this character this
is a decade Decker original we're poor
though
[Music]
no god damn it it's happening what the
what this is like my version of Ben's c4
you know it's a good song plays
whistling it is it's that or class cuz
claps let's you know what have fun one
song is claps what is the review coming
out the review is up on our site for
online everybody has it will be checking
it out
yeah before that it had been trained in
our Australia office you'll be checking
it out for finalizing that making sure
online works I'll be interested if I
stick to online because with brawl and
we you I had to say a little bit and I
was like ah Stas den just actually I
think like if I read the problem with
brawl was that like it's pretty limited
in what you can play some tenants don't
figure out how online yeah
oh you saved me sound like here we go
you saw Joe Joe it's here everyone's
here
and Tanaka that's a really good oh by
the way is a method yeah the biggest cop
yeah
it's the word yeah me pegs are all cops
sending that all of us are the cops oh
yeah we all have a fight it we're all
well the knees that the fighters are
based off of
oh my doing you know that's fine
misfit this that's all right I'm not
gonna win how did we let this happen
because these planes wish
that's that's the ultimate Lucas
maneuver is long everyone else is
fighting you just PK freeze everything
[Music]
on your face no bomb oh you stepped like
touch the way I'm very excited for the
new hand okay I know someone was asking
for king K rool I can't do that I'll be
cloud
all right into a cloud ah Robin
someone's asking for that for a bit
and then what does Cali get some one
thing you do
Mewtwo there was her was got a call from
you to see Megaman my wing Victor stop
dr. wily Megaman
often steam ahead dragon roost Meta
Knight someone did say YouTube for Kali
oh there you go there you go
it's official thanks for streaming this
of course thank you for hanging out
thanks for hanging out man
hope you guys are having a wonderful day
we've decided to play with all of you
guys tomorrow yeah if you just join
tomorrow we are going to be streaming
with the community so if you purchase
the game and you want to get in we'll
make that happen I don't know how I
imagine this is it makes a great here
now yeah we'll probably find yours just
to level the front there should because
we need every advantage of advantage we
can get against the community system who
did I say I was gonna play again shoot
you gonna meet you Robin
yeah there was an anime Harry Potter
Robin every single time here Robin oi
[Music]
Craigslist don't like Jake play again
for me tell me doesn't need to come back
to work tomorrow I'd be more afraid of
cash so you guys just gonna play we're
trying to do guys in on it he's dead
already
it's okay I don't really like the stage
yes this is like left read yes but they
completely like redid it or like it
looks really nice oh it's cloud like
snow tracks - it's the other one that I
didn't like very much hey also like
Phantom Hourglass although it does have
fun I like trains
zelich is a really good
[Laughter]
all that trains excuse me look how cool
I look like this big sword over there
[Music]
oh my god Oh God well also if you want
to know what every single final smash
looks like there's a video of that on
GameSpot that I painstakingly did 200%
check it out very here's watch I
attacked clout a lot yeah I'm sure there
was a fan I was like considering not
doing it and then I thought of that like
wait a second I could have cloud be the
dummy and every single one of these it's
like so much this it's perfect this is
for Ben I appreciate it I watched it was
more an accident and Sam watching Hannah
I don't think one person and when I like
to slow in one person notice they were
like poor cloud Nintendo or Sony
betrayed him or something okay
[Applause]
there's a lot of nonsense that just
happens
I thought that was the big one well
thank you me no I did God's got already
as it should be
wait a minute I have no idea how my
meter works last one your meters oh yes
sir you can check your sword I think are
your vows I tell you how close is
breaking so I cannot remember that I saw
breaks yeah Gary
[Music]
[Music]
no I was so thinking that that wasn't
going to hit anyone
I'm gonna go over there I know what's
gonna happen that trains gonna leave
called it my clockwork
no you're too good
can't believe this look stressful to
watch surviving longer in the quarter
yeah right sorry make sure everyone
knows that we're here why is chrome
there to steal the victory ah yeah what
the heck it's like a tuxedo mask
situation he shows up and say yeah
should do anything prom see you later
[Music]
hey do you guys play pokemon trainer I
was thinking that we got pac-land
yet oh my god play Ryu Youth peach yeah
yeah I'll be back
Megaman all right so that's perfectly
good Megaman someone wanted Ridley
[Music]
Bayonetta so that's from beta in awhile
I'll pick theta again someone was asking
for them
[Music]
and then we'll do ryu after someone
who's also basket for real
[Music]
I'm so afraid to say anything above
metric don't know how to pronounce any
of the names but I like Metroid a lot
it's like is it brinstar or brine star
oh yeah I remember people telling me
that same which is pretty shameless
definitely stay on this like but it's
spelled just like Sheamus and like
pretty sure that's not true after that
somebody wants to see Dracula's castle
they say was gonna be really good
Castlevania remixes yeah there
definitely are shoving green or red
green start with alpha sorry lieutenant
I'm sorry hack man
I don't seen anyone play pac-man yeah I
don't think anyone in this office is a
Jackson you know who plays a lot of
pac-man
that surprised me Hunter Pence oh yeah I
didn't know I didn't know that he played
a lot of smash but else in the building
he like he loves planes pac-man also
turns out he's a pretty good at Super
Smash Bros he's very good oh my shoe
[ __ ]
I've got jump down I'm already more you
all together yeah
jump shoot man speaking about famous
people playing video games
lady gaga playing baby another of my
favorite thing would it just makes so
much sense we've written right into that
and I'm just trying to find my way right
now
I haven't played much Megaman favorite
community oversized bullet scene you
just hide under a platform and do it
[Music]
keep the gun the gun yeah I stopped the
rain job I love it Jesus what was sort
of rewrite mr. I keep seeing bolster I'm
sorry really good I wish they separated
the characters to be honest because I
just plays I just like that was like
pretty chart laughs yeah but only
Charizard so you couldn't be like
squirtle which I was kind of fine with
but not being Bulbasaur reserves won't
get away
on your event Fat Boy seen tell me that
I had
[Music]
well now our chars are
oh and chars arts gosh so I get for
using his tongue side B Oh No
whoa this is so hectic what is why about
doing that I'll watch
[Applause]
No
No
holy Pascha watch out here - Aaron one
of the reasons why I like picking green
over red - is that Red's voice is really
annoying in this game really yeah so
this is a best character words
characters Rick Fox best characters
Isobel
without a doubt yeah that's just like
the official ranking horse characters I
sit all yours characters cloud oh yeah
he's pretty good and it's his recovery
that's really bad they're all ready for
that and then the Davis 3 man saved me
it's the Nintendo server down it is it
as far as service as a whole as far as
this game goes what they're like it's
not going live - no it's like now but
like no one has it so oh all right oh my
god nice the real test where the
server's work will be at what 9 p.m.
Pacific wind yeah the market really I
should probably download that yeah oh
yeah I mean it's not a huge game and
I'll play a cute I love myself yes
listen
oh now 13 gigs I think with my crew load
and I want to get homage just do that
right away
I mean Georgia canary true
Mega Man with a scythe is also a good
Ock no no no you just catch my saw yeah
come on razor leaf that works
[Music]
what though power
[Music]
oh they're ten gigabytes of off the
switch but not a big engine download
yeah definitely benefits to get that
like by there's a small SD cards I got
about 128 right way yeah I think I
actually upgraded mine this Black Friday
to a 409 whoa takes up to 400 yes
that's pretty I actually it almost
filled up my 130 okay I know somebody
really wanted records yeah I'm gonna do
Vampire Killer cuz they're killing it's
like what a question
it's the champ that's pretty good uh I
don't know if anyone you recognize
anything else I think so what do we do
like on it
just get some some classic its new throw
bags it's to the left and down to the
left
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so it really wants ice
climbers I can I can take someone's be
ice pack okay
blobby ice climbers I won't take one for
the team to pac-man let's see what else
all Phu match I'm down anything from me
so Z I met a knight and 1/2 minute mate
I can do bed at night I don't think I've
played Meta Knight since brawl but
someone said DDD which we got oh shoot
I've does predict it might've even know
so it says Isabela software it's how I
can go back to Sao Paulo there's so much
cool Jigglypuff King K rool snake Rio oh
I'm sorry that one person is asking for
you after I apologized I'm actually I'm
very good hey this is gonna be you know
what that's fine I know exactly what's
happening you're just gonna
take it look it's it's his most buff
move and just not let me not let me show
it off that's this is my favorite Sam's
in this game if you want 3d modeller
like a 2d to spray dirty like in the
style of diary I just want the
megalovania remix yeah that's the side
you hold enough for I want it's like
final to me like she puts you on the
stage and then has all the moves can I
have no idea okay don't stop eating me
times that you're not bad
Dadar bad no you know all that whoops
what was that I don't know I threw it
too quickly
oh good idea being friend dear friend
friend part of like the charm of Earth
that is how good how bad the good or how
good the bad translations are yeah
probably who is me
oh he just eats everything yeah like
that whoa God
all right let's pretty good Oh didn't
get out there's one thing I'm good at
its avoidance stuff
got cars every time
but I like how it just comes back like
on the proper lights and LED let's
really now wonder if that's just
coincidental evacuate time it Oh beep
fire
that's that's okay that's alright
and so DLC predictions you've been
talking a lot about sans I mentioned
banjo once who does everyone want for
that remix looked like a hard set like
the old mouse I mean I want Gino just
for - I feel Geno's gotta be a sugar
Gino's a trophy no he's not that's what
I don't think you can eat Gino costumes
on which you could and we you yeah I
think it's just right is one which is
why like spirit I think that's why you
may actually see him the only thing that
makes anything stands wooden business
cuz they said like they kind of pick him
a while yeah but least I've Nintendo
with oh no actually no they said
Nintendo adjust the just civilized and
it did come on switch this year so hey
buddy came out like we don't know how
long that I know I hope I'm hopeful but
it it feels like the timing could see a
little fun uh I'm gonna throw it out
there again you don't even have to worry
about that because clouds in the game
and he's not on any Nintendo games Joe
[Music]
it's very early Oh actually he's on the
smash bros wiiu I know one of them is an
assist trophy I'm kind of surprised no
wives characters were uh okay
yeah Susan Bucher I'm mostly gonna bring
in anyone as an actual character yeah I
don't think so uh yeah that guitarist I
didn't do any chaos ice climbers are a
Paper Mario that's actually not a bad
yeah I have is like hammer and every you
could probably do like what one more
yeah I was thinking one more it's almost
twelve thirty Rosen stream for an hour
oh if you like you I I will do why don't
we do one more recommendations as well
and then we pick whatever character okay
so I'll definitely do review because
that one person basket yeah doing hit
only yes
sorry um see let's see Shante we're
shocked you actually kind of cool oh
yeah Alex today same way man so slippery
man so lame able to make a lot of sense
with Ubisoft too and like the stuff
they've been doing together
yeah rabbits for the rapid I hope not
even if you I have is a Cisco be fine
but just and I also grant do not want
that let's see uh someone wants Oh Lamar
there's Isabella Omar's in it no no
don't like to play oh yeah like a peach
you Ganondorf
so incensed more you seen them stage
where you have to final yeah I'll be
I'll take one for the team would be all
about some sort of snake but that's okay
cuz I think I'll probably pick snakes in
space to the last one yeah peach you
kromm game and watch I'll do Chrome for
the last one I'm gonna Picchu Machu
Picchu
and you real team schools here I'm never
wearing that Julie puffed cloud do the
bandana that's my favorite one
just don't want to do it game watch as
long as I do play I'm gonna watch over
out helpful more that's one of them you
know at all I can go with all Marcil
along yeah yeah let's do that because
some of those people are recommending
we've already placed em off I guess I
got this big peachy and then throw a
couple for Pichu so I
[Music]
ah here we are the enviable melee stage
[Music]
now where some of them they like redid
and others they they kind of kept the
same textures here just hurting himself
Oh bandana I might pick nits are dead
we're picking it ones exactly but
they're not the same as the last one
what's it put a sock arrived again I got
you
I put it like that yeah I'm being over
the Reggie petition to Reggie the Hajis
how come GameSpot have this game we have
it because it's a early copy for review
is that the longer you play a game on
stream though like harbor words are
especially cuz like there's no one
person really hosting oh yeah she was
the gun troop one we're on it I was not
paying attention where did you pick this
job no I am it was a good call oh yes
it's table once this is that poker float
so like what do we this is the new photo
floats a puzzle isn't so bad Pyramus I
hope afloat so your is it is playing
right now what it's been a long long
everything no no Rick time
although the jetpack just makes sense Oh
God thank God
[Applause]
[Music]
finish this before to come back to pack
[Music]
[Music]
one change that I really like that's
like you'll probably forget pretty
quickly is there's not a separate mode
for a Twitter smash it's just like it's
all there just keep jumping right in
yeah everybody's like it's good as
little as it sounds that is such a nice
quality of life changes I also like the
fact you can save move sense yeah that's
all think they did a really good job on
just like the presentation as a whole
and then use it it feels really like
intuitive fine we're fine
yes
[Music]
well there goes game and watch it all
the more wind I swear to God
no pressure-treated I want to hit you
with but it was different players online
this time eight I know you can do like
tag team stuff with someone on your same
console a lot of Kalos oh heck yeah so
now we're doing whatever we want on
Margaery Mushroom Kingdom mushrooms so I
believe this one right
oh no way is that just me Peach's castle
f I don't want it and I think Mushroom
Kingdom is I think it was over to the
right as Mushroom Kingdom
- and that's the regional mustard I
think it was probably you know I think I
would they says that's gonna be honest
I'm totally for that we try and scroll
back - I think it's Mushroom Kingdom
[Music]
oz new ground theme remix all that's
Pleasant
[Music]
okay no good music let's oh you know we
haven't done we've done the Hyrule
Castle like the IRA one temple example
it's like the does my favorite stage oh
I don't like it cause it's too big but I
like it because he's like this was the
stage that we would only ever play in LA
oh my god yes like we only ever played
temple I do this in coronary it'll just
switch between the two
someone asked if they changed the way
snake looks yeah they did he style a bit
differently but still their toe down the
bottom yeah buts yeah unless their
favorite ones butts have been nerfed
except appreciate everyone's butts
aren't here
[Applause]
all right the final smash of the day
this is Emma tomorrow if you guys
purchase the game you want to play with
us
we'll have that set up sometime tomorrow
doing that and yeah we're gonna be
hanging out soon but we have the Game
Awards happening tonight
you don't you want to check it out and
we'll be streaming an unannounced game
after right
it's not even announced I'll be
stringing a game after showing through
some cool stuff see I'm sure to stick
around hang out with us it'll be fun
we'll have all the news and stuff and
announcements from the game awards also
can these wall editorials for that
[Music]
everyone I met I always like starting
missing the news team then I'm like no
way all of it is very alone and I just
screwed up two fights [ __ ] I'm offended
oh oh that is bull [ __ ] men not not the
best place for that oh that was almost
that was dumb
what is happening see poor job at sea or
it's always been see for all this
transition is wild that's young
ah okay nope no no nope
tons that's the problem this stage it's
about here telling a lie yeah
[Music]
no oh just missed literally everyone
can't believe this
you can spot for long cuz you got high
what happens to the bomb on transitions
I think it just probably gets dropped
all that star is kind of takes it - yeah
what did you put that there
yeah
oh yeah
[Music]
I would love to win a game I wanted last
night a nice safe here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh No
Oh God
my wife Oh
[Music]
[Music]
it's alright
Ben needs to go no I'm good everything's
fine dang it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow okay you look it's that directional
influence
[Applause]
[Music]
down there now I believe I can't let me
win the two wives
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh there we go
ah it's not over solid
[Applause]
[Music]
you think it's Taylor that we all really
like this day yes yeah it's like event
200% it is the ultimate version of Super
Smash Bros I would say yeah yeah just my
opinion no not here you box out yes
there you go alright well there you have
it that is Super Smash Bros ultimate we
will be streaming this again tomorrow so
please come back especially if you get
the game because we will be challenging
people in the community yes you can show
us how to play smash or maple beat you
will see I've been later tonight we are
also after the game Awards we will be
streaming a first look at a game that
there which has already been revealed I
don't want to say too much is the case
yeah and bargains stuff but come back
here tonight after the game wards
because the game that will be showing
looks pretty rad yeah yes and thank you
guys for joining me for this thanks for
watching yeah thanks guys
yeah thanks for tuning in having all
your questions and character
recommendations see ya
[Music]